i'm going to tell a story i don't know
if you know um but when you ran for
president
in 2016 um you started like the pack to
end all packs
um and i donated i was like wow great
idea
like this guy is on to something you
know now the story
my story i actually think of as a story
of optimism
because you know in 2016 it was my view
it's actually 2015 when we started this
it was my view that unless we got
the nation to focus on the fundamental
problem of the corruption of this
democracy
nothing else was possible i mean you
know you got these candidates like
bernie and hillary up on stage talking
about all the amazing things they're
gonna do you should have been on stage
too man
we were talking about that what was that
yeah they they changed the rules on you
right
yeah so so i wanted to get them to focus
on these fundamental issues and i said
like
i will run for president if i can raise
a million dollars in 30 days
and um and the way i'd run for president
is by making this issue the number one
issue the issue i talked about before
anything else like we have to commit to
fixing democracy first
and so we raised the money in less than
30 days and uh
and until you're like oh my gosh now i
have to do it right right
but the pollsters that we you know we
had said look um
based on what we we know you're gonna
qualify for the debates
the first challenge was that the
democratic party had a rule that said
that you had to be
uh uh you had to be listed on a certain
list of polls
and those polling companies were not
including my name
um so there's this i just want to stop
you there lawrence that was actually
really tricky for us too
yeah in 2018 they they had a bunch of
polls
and my name was not on them and then
you're like well if i'm not on the poll
then it's gonna be very hard to qualify
it does so leading up to the first
debate uh bloomberg
uh wrote up the bloomberg press wrote a
big editorial about how ridiculous this
was because you could tell from
other polling that i would have
qualified but i wasn't on the approved
list
my view at that point was okay their
rule was here's the approved list you
got to be on that list
fine the next time around we'll make it
a week before
uh at the end of october um my campaign
manager called me and he said you know
we're going to qualify you're going to
be in the next debate um
and i said oh you know he said you got
to get to work and preparing so i
drilled down to begin to prepare and
then at the end of the week he called me
back and he said
uh the democratic party has just changed
the rules for the debate you're not
going to qualify
and they had they had recrafted the rule
to like draw the boundary precisely
so that i would not qualify according to
their new specified rules
um and uh and so you know when it was
clear they were gonna
change what was the new boundary what
was the old boundary what was it well so
the rules they had originally announced
which they eventually agreed this were
there were the rules was that you had to
be at one percent
in three polls within six weeks of the
debate very reasonable
and then they uh changed the rules to
say you had to be greater than one
percent
in three polls and then they gave a
period
carving out the time before the debate
and that period was carved to
lop off polls that had qualified me
and there we knew what other polls were
going to be announced and there weren't
going to be enough polls that were
announced to
qualify come on point that that was a
coincidence
they they consulted the stars
that there was somebody off that
conformed
to somebody wrote me and said
pulse of the nation right somebody wrote
me and said that's with larry mandering
born
you got very commander that's right
but anyway i mean you know the point was
it was clear
they didn't want somebody up on stage
causing trouble around this issue
and you know they saw what donald trump
was doing
on the on the republican stage i don't
blame them in some sense but
they didn't want this issue to be
central when i tried to talk about this
issue as being central people are like
you know no no people care about
healthcare they care about they care
about climate change they care about
student debt
well that was like a danger larry is
that um
it it seems no offense to you but you
seem like a very smart guy
and so so like that the danger when you
talk about
the and you should know that um i i came
away also convinced
by our event together where i was like
he's right uh democracy reform
needs to be front and center because
we'll never actually change anything
meaningful without it
um but the the the hazard i think that
people have when you talk about it
is they think in terms of process that's
what i meant by the smart guy it's like
a smart guy you have some fixes
to to the process uh and the the danger
is that people will just be like oh
you know like that this stuff is going
to be wonky and
uninteresting but it seems like you've
had a different experience when you talk
about this because
americans realize that we right now are
not functioning
in a democracy that's living up to the
name yeah and this is what's so
hopeful i think you know in 2016 i
couldn't get them to talk about this you
in 2020
you know our group and represent us and
end citizens united
succeeded in getting every major
democratic candidate
you were one of the first to commit to
fundamental democratic reform in the
first hundred days of their
administration
including finally uh um joe biden
but i thought most dramatically was
bernie sanders who finally came around
to embracing vouchers which you had
embraced back in
april of 2019 and he had an incredibly
powerful
story about why vouchers were so
fundamental shifting power to ordinary
voters
so that they are the one driving
fundraising and the intention of
candidates
um and so you know my view is we've come
a long way in five years
we came from the issue not even you
recognize this no no no no it's not just
me
no no i mean there are a lot of people
that helped you a lot of people right
when we think about this issue though
uh you are the first name that comes to
mind right so so i think we're at this
moment where you know the house of
representatives passed hr one in 2019
the most important reform legislation
passed by the house since the voting
rights act of 1965.
um if we get the senate if we send the
dark lord mitch mcconnell back to
kentucky
and we get the presidency there is a
chance that a year from now
we will look at what happened and say
holy [ __ ] we have
passed fundamental reform including
public funding of congressional
campaigns and i hope um
including something more like what you
were talking about vouchers to help
drive that funding
democracy dollars yeah yeah which is
what you were very clear right up front
and then
it was so funny kirsten gillibrand's
campaign i was talking to and they're
like andrew yang says a hundred dollars
hell we're gonna say six hundred dollars
six hundred dollars per voter if
if you have three three campaigns of
president senate and house in in one
cycle
so you sparked that's right
so i i think we have a real shot if we
can just get beyond the disaster
that is uh looming in november of 2020.
this is very optimistic and hr one has
many tremendous reforms in it
um what are like the top reforms that
you're excited about and to the extent
hr one's missing anything
is it missing something yeah the most
important thing in hr one is public
funding
it's missing a more robust
voucher component because the kind of
public funding it's framed around is
matching funds which is what new york
city does
and matching funds are great very
helpful but the point is you're still
appealing to a relatively small smoker
i mean you know most most rich people
don't realize that the average american
can't just write a check for 100 to a
politician that's just not within their
capacity but if they had a 100 democracy
dollar the way you were talking about it
of course what else are going to do with
it they're going to give it to
politicians so the point is
that's a more fundamental reform we've
got to build in and i know the sponsors
of hr1 are eager to think about how to
expand it so
hr1 that's the most important thing that
gerrymandering reform is incredibly
important the restoration of the voting
rights act
is astonishing that we're still fighting
about this issue but
yes that's incredibly important what
it's missing
is is much stronger support for rank
choice voting
yeah that would have been exploding
would have been extremely important in
this democratic primary
um uh um you know as well as having an
iowa
caucus that actually worked that would
have been helpful too but
um you know i think that that's
something a lot of people are talking
about now we could we could begin to get
towards
um but i think those are the central
most important things that that bill
carried well it would be a great leap
forward to have
um matching funds for these
congressional campaigns because when
some of the candidates were seeing are
generating popular enthusiasm and that
if you got a bunch of small dollar
donors
it could add up quickly but i agree with
you people don't realize what a big deal
it is for someone to donate
10 20 50 bucks to a political campaign
uh one people don't have any disposable
income lying around
in that way like if you think fifty a
hundred dollars to them that's like a
really
big deal but the second thing is people
are so burnt by politics that it
takes like a really big
connection or attachment to motivate
someone to donate to a candidate it's
one reason why i'm so appreciative of
the
yang gang rallying behind my campaign
because i was really bad at dialing for
dollars uh larry i was terrible at it so
i was like oh man i hope some
everyday america works the worst
you know when i was doing it and i did
it very little when we came to
you know close to getting to the million
dollars my campaign manager sat me down
and said you've got to call these people
and make sure it happens okay so i did
it
but the thing i was thinking as i was
doing it is okay i hate this
every normal person would hate this what
kind of person
likes this because you know that's the
kind of person
we're attracting to run for congress and
you're like do we really want
our nation represented by the sort of
person who likes sucking up to rich
people from money because
that's not how you build leadership in a
nation i joke about it all the time
that you'd have to be out of your mind
to go to a cubicle farm and dial for
dollars and think that was the way it
ought to be
uh the problem is that as soon as you're
in that cubicle farm then you're like
well i had to
swim through [ __ ] to get here yeah and
so now this system's going to protect me
because i'm an incumbent i start out
with let's say a million dollar
advantage over
uh tom dicker sally or whoever's gonna
run against me
uh so here it is like this moat
now benefits me so i guess i will
suck it up and take advantage of the
fact that i can do a soul-crushing
activity better than the next person
the most depressing story i heard a
member of congress told me he said you
know
one of the things about congress is it's
totally broken institution nothing
happens
and it turns out fundraising is the one
thing where you feel like you've
accomplished something so it's like
doing push-ups so he says like
i can go down for an hour and i can have
my target
and i can meet my target i can feel like
holy [ __ ] i did something i accomplished
something today
and you're like oh my god this system is
now built so that the only thing you
feel proud of
is your ability to raise money because
you can't do anything else you can't
legislate you can't work with anybody
you can't bring about
government services anybody's respectful
of it's just fundraising that is the
measure of success
that is very dark and very human and so
important there was a person running for
president
hopefully he doesn't mind that i say
this uh but senator michael bennett
and one of my colleagues was with him
on the plane and was like hey so what's
motivating the run and he said honestly
it's so i can try and get something done
because i'm not getting [ __ ] done
in the senate because we don't pass
anything
yeah and so it speaks to the same thing
where if you have a good person who
wants to accomplish something
unfortunately dialing for dollars at
least gives them that momentary
reinforcement
that they they got something good done
or good i mean you know
they succeeded yeah yeah that's like
such a microcosm of something i i think
so here what are the things
i said on the trail was that in american
life today if you have money on one side
and people on the other
the money's going to win like who's
going to win and people all like
uniformly in my events they were like
yeah the money's going to win and so
this is the case i made for a democracy
dollar i said we have to unify the
people on the money and then you have a
chance
then the legislators are responding to
you again
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode